[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants vous faut que
le petit enfant allons à l'ombre aux
ours bout dépêche toi d'aller voir petit
louis et mirabel nous avons encore une
très longue tournée à faire ce soir -
patron jambes et pêche et ce soir je
n'oublierai pas votre commission europe
promis juré et fait attention de ne pas
être trop gourmand oui ce serait un gros
big up pour la tiba messieurs s'il vous
plaît un gros pour moi et trois petits
pots mais enfin ils sont petits veaux
enfin monsieur très petits au bol en
suisse on qui on va leur faire des
petits bifteck bientôt oui messieurs
s'il vous plaît bien le bonjour monsieur
le marchand au beau vieux monsieur
bonjour je vois là madame mirabel merci
monsieur le boucher et qu'est ce que je
vous des coupes monsieur gros saumons
rouges y ont donc en ton nom
ce soir je ne ferai rien pour moi mais
tu lis ma charge et d'une commission
weight attentes et je les écris sur un
petit bout de papier ne pourrai pas
l'oublier nous a surtout pas du chocolat
le voilà à lyon voit lyon 1 1 kg de
sable fin et pour ulysse
[Musique]
c'est parce qu'elle a un charme sable il
a besoin de beaucoup de sable car lui en
faut pour tous les petits enfants et le
soir quand il est l'heure d'aller aux
totaux l'urne envoie quelques grains
dans les yeux des enfants et ceux ci
ferme vite leurs yeux et s'endorment
tout de suite il faut que je m'en aille
sinon lys va de nouveau gronder au
revoir les enfants au revoir je vais
regarder un petit peu si ce sable et
bien fin le
[Musique]
on ira bel boni petit louis dans mes
vite les petits enfants vous voilà pas
trop vous ai apporté votre sobre merci
nounours tu es très gentil mais tu en as
mis du temps j'ai bien l'impression que
tu ne va pas tarder à dormir toi aussi
allons en route
à demain bonne nuit
[Musique]
oh
en
[Musique]